hey there i'm sam
i'm here today at chrome dev summit to
talk about your cache how it works
and how to use it to best benefit your
users especially focusing on the second
load of your sites
i'm just really excited to talk to you
today so i know a lot of guidance out
there
only focuses on the first load this is
an intermediate talk
although i'll try to avoid getting
overly technical i will be assuming some
basic knowledge about
how the web and how http works i've also
written an article to go along with this
video
so please check it out if you'd like to
follow along to start off i'm going to
set up some of the goals of this talk
give you a well-lit path and then talk
through some of the classic caching
pitfalls
when we talk about the second load and
making that work well there's really
two big goals first you want to make
sure that when you release a new version
of your site or update your content
users should get the new version almost
immediately but secondly
we want to do as little work as possible
to get here and this means we don't want
to redownload everything
if you're just making a small change and
that fundamentally means using the
browser's cache
so this is why i'm speaking today it's
about the second load and using the
cache really well
to make sure that your users have a
great experience with your content
but first i'd like to dispel this myth
that the web is at one end of these two
extremes
as i mentioned you could go to the
network for every resource and always as
far as
site is up to date albeit a bit slowly
you can also put everything in a cache
and be fast but maybe out of date and
your user site's already there ready to
go
but this isn't really the case you can
be in the middle
i want to start with a case study i work
on google's developer documentation site
web.dev
and in july this year we run a virtual
conference web.dev
live the conference site was built as a
microsite inside web.dev
and included a bunch of interactive
elements including a video player and a
chat component
but it had a problem where users might
not get the latest version of the css
and javascript needed to run the
microsite
and those components in the end would
just fail to work
for the rest of the site for code loves
and articles and so on we had gone to
one end of the extreme
we'd catch the entire site in the
pursuit of loading fast
by our service worker that used workbox
now to be fair we always wanted the
network to load article content but then
we rendered it inside a shell which we
cased already
this contains our sites html css
javascript and so on
i do want to be really clear this
actually worked really well for articles
and we were kind of spoiled by that we
only fetched the actual bytes containing
the raw text most laws were only a few
kilobytes into the network
and this made our experience really
quite fast and these elements live in
harmony
then everything changed and in building
the micro site we realized that our
really aggressive caching
could cause the user's case to get stuck
without loading the new required
dependencies
now to be fair we eventually found a
workaround and the site works a bit
differently now
but in the end we backed ourselves into
a corner this big learning here
is that the sites don't really just
exist in a git repo they also exist on a
server somewhere
but finally really in the caches
of all your clients all around the world
and you have to be holistic when you
think about doing updates on that
before i continue i do want to call it
again a lot of guidance on there
only focuses on the first load
experience this is still really valuable
for attracting users and making sure
they have a great first experience
but if you're only optimizing this
picture this lighthouse scores
for a first load then you could be
causing users who come back to have a
worse experience
and it's important to remember here that
core web vitals which show up in a bunch
of places including the chrome ux report
include all loads not just the first
load lighthouse despite being a great
tool
is entirely designed to empty your cache
and show what a first load feels like
in a bunch of different environments it
doesn't have any provision for the
second load
for me what i want to fundamentally
propose in this talk is a well-lit
path for caching which will benefit
users on their second load
we honestly think that a sensible
default vacation is actually to not
cache by default so there's nuance to
this of course
i suggest using a cdn which is a
globally distributed way to bring your
content close to your users
and use validation to make sure that
your site is up to date without
transferring it completely
and this is obviously a pretty extreme
point of view but to me this is just the
same
modern default you can then opt in to
better caching rules as you need them
so in this talk i'll be talking a lot
about immutable assets which is the
other extreme
urls that will tell the browser cache
forever because they have a unique
hash name but i think there's a big
problem with this weird middle ground
if you don't quite understand what your
cache is doing and you don't
define really clearly clear rules this
can be quite dangerous as you really
might not
understand why something is either
broken or you're burning through network
traffic
and this leads me into goals for you as
developers and i think it's important
for me to call this out
my goal in the end is to help you be
lazy and the modern web is super
complicated which turns out
makes that really hard many sites are
fully integrated pages which only
require work if their css javascript
html
is all in perfect sync and as we saw
that for web.dev
live but we we tend to think that
historically
caching is a bit fuzzy and most people
today try to patch that
rather than going back to a sensible
default and lastly of course it's also
about reducing actual network traffic
it's not just about developer complexity
for you but also about saving bandwidth
and of course i want to reduce your
stress levels for web dev live turns out
this was a pretty stressful moment for
me as a developer i risked my users
having a bad time
so what does having a bad time actually
mean
i talked about web.dev but let's talk
about where poor caching strategies show
up in the real world
and i confess this area is kind of the
stick of the talk
but i think it's something we need to
need to talk about bad caging rules tend
to show up as something known as stale
assets
as web developers we're so used to doing
a hard reload when our sites just don't
look right you know i do it literally
i'll hit ctrl shift r
or open a tab in incognito and i have a
question for all of you watching
if you're testing a site on your phone
how do you do a hard reload on mobile
turns out there's no button for that
i've got to manually click the cache and
do a bunch of stuff
there's no key code for that and here
are some examples of what a stale asset
really looks like for real world end
users
all these people are trying to load
their sites as a second load they have
something broken
in their cage from a previous load and
they want to come back and get more of
whatever they've been loading before
and these companies have no real
recourse except to tell users that this
weird step
that they might not really understand
and good luck your site
might come good if you're lucky so
what's the cause of these problems
well there is a bunch but a common one
really is not giving the browser any
instructions
turns out if i don't give a browser any
instructions if i say absolutely nothing
the browser will actually guess how long
to cache your file for
it uses a concept called heuristic
freshness you can search for that term
it's in the spec
how this works is if a file was created
you know years ago
but you fetch it today your browser will
still catch you for 10 at that time
so for a year old file that'll be
another 36 days
this becomes a real problem when i have
lots of assets that were created at
different times
when i do my first load and then come
back with a different last modified
header
these assets will be caged for different
times so when i do my second load as you
can see here
i'm actually might actually be getting a
cache version of some files
but not of others and even more
confusingly as a bit of an aside
different browsers actually implement
this differently some browsers will
always fetch the html they'll assume
it's always out of date
but they might skip the css and
javascript
so having no rules this might have been
fine in the 90s or early 2000s but this
ambiguity
it's dangerous for today's modern web so
i've introduced some of the concepts
described our world at path and talked
about some second load failure cases
let's move on and i want to talk about
some of the concepts that i kind of
glossed over
cdns how the headers work that really
make this caching story really make
sense
and the sorts of files you might be able
to make immutable
so let's start with cdns as i mentioned
before cdns are a way to replicate your
content
quite physically close to your users
wherever they are geographically around
the world
bringing the latency down we've also got
a great article on this on web.dev so
please check that out
this fundamentally means that when i
disable caching as i kind of suggest in
the welded path
i can really validate quickly i can make
sure this is up to date because the
content is actually physically quite
close to me
for me i live in australia which is
turns out far away from a lot of the
content that i'm really interested in
so if a site isn't using a cdn it's
going to the origin host of where the
content
is originally from turns out i can
really feel that latency it might add a
couple hundred milliseconds to my round
trip
so what i'm trying to say is while you
have a bunch of options in terms of what
cdn you might end up using
maybe consider using one where your
users are going to be
and how your cdn choice is made
might be influenced by that so
let's talk about the cache control http
header it's really the master knob that
we have as web developers to control how
browsers cache assets
and how they'll be used for the second
load throughout the talk i'll give you a
few suggestions of how to use this
but i'm going to talk through all the
different options and mini knobs that
you have on this setting
i also mentioned expires here only to
kind of largely let you know that you
can't ignore it
it's completely now replaced by cache
control
so let's talk about these knobs again
max age tells a browser how long they
can hold onto a file for
after the time it was served how long is
it valid for after you received it must
validate says
after that same time you really can't
use this file it makes the max age age
a strict requirement as opposed to a
loose requirement
public and private go together for now
let's just say that private is important
when you're serving
like a logged in page that you generate
on the server that you don't want other
people to cache
no store is actively disabling caching
the
client and any cdn along the way will
completely ignore this file
this is not just going to validate the
browser will never put this in storage
lastly immutable which i'll explain a
little bit more later it's something
that should be on by default
but it has a few new answers so next we
have the etag header
i've sort of mentioned validation a few
times already in this talk the way this
works is
when you do a network request to a
server for the second time your computer
or device
will pass along the e-tag from any
previous response that you've received
if the e-tag matches you'll get the
status code of three 304
this means you don't have to download
the file again you've probably seen this
all over the internet and it means that
you cut down
on your bandwidth cost it still has
latency cost which is really important
i've got to go to the cdn or the origin
server to validate whether the file is
still the same
for small files this kind of has
diminishing returns by the time i do my
request to check the file is the same
i can almost just get the file again as
a bit of a side note
one thing to remember is every http
request might say
cost you about a kilobyte if your file
is vastly less than that
i often encourage users developers to
actually put those files inside base64
versions inside css or html
having more assets isn't always a good
thing
with some background aside let's go back
to that well-lit path that i introduced
earlier
and the modern sensible default location
so http has been around for a long time
i mentioned that last modified default
behavior that's really not new being
introduced in about 1999
and browsers still don't implement it
correctly i really do think it's time
for an update
and to restate our goal we kind of oddly
want to disable caching
don't cache by default and just validate
the resources are up to date via etags
then introduce more caching rules while
also bringing your content close to the
users
by cdns so i want to talk about how you
might configure your cdns
i've put etags only on the slide for
completeness nearly every web server or
web host in the world is going to be
serving this properly
it can be a tiny bit tricky if you're
generating content dynamically
rather than just serving real files on
disk but even that's more or less
solvable
and the most important part of this talk
is encouraging you to set cache control
to this
that you see here this basically means
this file is valid for no time at all
you can serve it once and then after
zero seconds you must go back and check
that it's valid
and also it's public so a cdn along the
way can cache it
the last point is tricky if a file is
not valid for any amount of time
then how can your cdn actually cache it
shouldn't it throw it away
well turns out cdns will often have a
much clearer and complete view of your
site than your end user's browser
they're actually often moving your file
close to your end users
and serving it from there so now you
know how to configure them
i want to mention some great cdn options
netlify
actually implements the behavior which
i'm talking about today and they have a
great article which describes
much like i'm doing in this talk why
they think it's a great idea
google also has a service called
firebase hosting which acts as a cdn
it doesn't quite match these semantics
by default but it's pretty easy to
configure and i recommend you check out
my article
to see how you might do that
of course it turns out like everything
just taking the approach i mentioned
verbatim in this talk has some downsides
let's cover some of them and how we can
work around them and make progress for a
better caching strategy
the really big one of course is that
this strategy works well for first of
all users on fast connections
for me in australia i live in sydney
where most of australia's internet staff
tends to live
i get ridiculously fast latency to a lot
of cdns often faster than 16
milliseconds which
is less than the time it takes to draw
one frame at 60fps
that's not so great for the people
living in other cities and definitely
not so good for people
in developing nations on 3d modems
next validation can still cause what's
known as critical request chains
this is something that also gets
reported in lighthouse and it's latency
bound
so the fact that validations are cheap
in terms of bytes doesn't really help us
it means that one file might request
another which requests another and so on
and this latency ends up compounding and
slowing down your loads of your site
and finally like i sort of hinted at
before having lots of small files even
though
that's pretty fast with http 2 turns out
it's still working you should do
so having fewer files to validate is
always going to improve your performance
but the bigger opt out which i've
already mentioned in this talk is that
for most sites
most assets just don't change every
release they're immutable
when you do a build and release of your
site you'll find that css javascript
html
whatever they don't all change at once
so what we recommend you do as much as
you can
is include a hash of the assets contents
in the file name itself
you can also put it in the query string
and i'll compare these two options later
most importantly and i want to make this
clear you shouldn't be doing this by
hand
we're now definitely getting into the
realm of build tools but of course just
renaming a file like this doesn't mean
anything to a browser
we need to actually set a header so we
do this by serving
with a different cache control header
you can catch these files with a regular
expression
check out the related article but like
look for long strings of hashes like you
see here
as for the header itself we said that
this file is valid for a long time
this value is a year and actually
according to the spec
anything over a year is according is
effectively equivalent to
forever we also need to say that it's
immutable
i mentioned immutable before but this is
the flag on cache control
i find this thing really confusing and i
think when most people learn about
caching they think it already works like
this
if i fetch the file and it's within this
age you can keep using it
but historically it was actually more of
a guideline so in 2017
chrome actually changed this behavior to
work as if immutable was always set
it was always true there's a great
article explaining why which i've linked
to below
so this immutable flag is really just
for other browsers which haven't caught
up
a few okay so you've configured your
site and now have a bunch of files that
look like this
but the real kicker here is that while
we can cache these assets
at the top we can't really cache
everything while a html file refers to
these files
you really can't tell users to navigate
to this long awkward index html file
that's clearly a terrible user
experience so the big conception about
making assets immutable is that you
can't really change your entry points to
work like this
they can't be served forever or made
immutable these files will always have
to be validated
or perhaps served with a middle ground
caching strategy so i wanted to grasp a
little bit
even if you aren't fully on board with
the advice in this talk a really
valuable thing that site authors can do
is really to try to create more of these
immutable assets fundamentally this is
something that will really help almost
every type of type of web experience
lastly before i talk a bit more on the
abject about tooling and the way you lay
out your site
i want to talk about the middle ground
i've really given you two extreme
options right
never cache or cache literally forever
and i think what fits into the middle
ground are assets which have low effect
on other files
these are files that don't include or
change other files
css for example is a really bad example
it has lots of effect on your html
good examples of files like images that
are part of your content because they
don't really import other things and if
they change over time
maybe because they're recompressed
that's not really a big deal i can keep
the old version around for a bit longer
so you can cache these things for like a
medium amount of time
so in the second section i want to talk
a bit about how the web is fundamentally
a connected graph
what that really means is your html
loads images or js or whatever
that might even load more content i'm
especially going to be focusing on
javascript
because byte for byte it's the most
expensive part of your site's load in
terms of cpu time
so here's a really simple example we
have an index page which loads two other
assets
i've marked assets here that aren't
immutable
or can't be treated as immutable in blue
of course
sites are actually lots of pages often
depending on the same assets
i want to mention this for you know to
be complete
but this example just assumes a single
file
and we want these files on the right our
css and javascript to be immutable if
they can be
and what i'm showing here is even though
the index page might change or
revalidate
when a user does the second load these
two files on the right which i'm showing
in red to show that they can be
immutable
don't need to be loaded from the network
we've got a hash we know that they're
not going to change
so when we get a new version of that
index page that's all we need
your browser will just say great i've
already got these dependent resources i
don't need them to fetch them again
here's your content your second load is
amazing
let's have a quick divergence on
javascript build systems one of the
reasons i want to talk about javascript
is that these build systems tools like
rollup and webpack
will often generate multiple files
they'll pull that shared code into
a common bundle so there's no
duplication so
to step back a bit these tools will
generate two classes of files
entry points which loaded directly by
your html inside script tags
and chunks which are these anonymous
bits of shared code
nearly everything in elsinore website
tends to be flat and not have this
additional loading cost based on these
connections what i find interesting
though is that these build tools will
often hash their anonymous chunks of
code
as you see on the right but they won't
hash their entry points at least not by
default
these files are still blue and can't be
cased forever they haven't got a unique
name we don't know if they've changed or
not
this means we now have two layers of
validation to perform which if
you remember before introduces what we
know as critical request chains
an extra round trip so why is this
turns out it's because these tools want
to be easy to use
and fundamentally they just don't know
about your html
what it means in practice is that your
html can
look like this in both development and
production and just point to a file of
the same name
but what you want to do is of course
rename your entry points
and add these hashes into your html like
you see in this example
adding these hashes into the place where
we depend on these files and this is
where your browser makes that critical
decision right you'll see this file with
a hash and go
great i've got this file already don't
need to go to the network
while i've kept this talk fairly
abstract i want to call out how we solve
this problem in web.dev we use 11t
the static site generator which uses
nunjucks internally for templating
for us we have a nunjuck's filter which
takes the name of a file and finds its
hash before
writing that out to the page in
production
this does what it says it spits out a
hash in our case
we use the query string approach this is
simpler and i'll mention that why in a
little bit
but in development this does actually
nothing it doesn't get in the way of our
fast reload and rebuilt cycle
and this works because our website is
configured to not
uh generate anything different from
terms of its cache headers this file
doesn't have a hash in it so the cache
header is exactly the same
so i've mentioned query strings versus
file names in practice it doesn't really
matter which one you choose your build
system might let you down one path
versus another and that's totally fine
in our experience if you have a choice
query strings
tend to be marginally safer especially
for entry points like your javascript
if for some unknown reason your users
have an old version of your html
they'll still get something if they load
this file the query string won't match
it'll be out of whack
in the end it's just kind of a hint to
the client but they'll still return a
file that
is on disk it's a bit of a safety net
and you might think that just renaming a
file works the same way you know i've
got an old version of that file
and a new version of that file but in my
experience most build systems in most
deployment environments tend to not
encourage you to keep around those old
files
so in fact it's kind of dangerous
because if you have a html file
referencing the old
name that old file's probably now
completely gone
so this hashing work is kind of an
interesting problem i've obviously
focused on javascript because i think
as well developers we're kind of used to
working with
it and having build systems around that
even for sites that are even just a
little bit complex
it can definitely work for other assets
too things like css images and so on
but as i mentioned before javascript is
really quite expensive
so i want to talk through another
approach of how we can avoid changing
our javascript altogether
if we don't need to so let's go back to
the simple example
i've got the single page and i've
compiled my source code into a single
file for it to load i've done all the
right things it's got a
nice name and it's immutable but if i
change even a single byte in my
javascript source code
my file will actually get renamed
something i've actually done myself by
accident
is include the current date and time in
the build and turns out
that's going to change every time i hit
that button so my hash was always new
don't be like me and don't do this lots
of build forms can actually help you
extract parts of your code into separate
bundles
in web.dev's case what we actually do is
split out the web component libraries
lit element and let html
into their own dependency file these are
actually npm dependencies we depend on
they're pretty stable we don't tend to
update them very often and they
don't actually have that many changes
build tools can help you pull out these
files but you might have to write some
code to do it
we fundamentally want to do this because
this dependency as i mentioned isn't
going to change way less than our core
code and so when we update our site and
change that core code
our updated html will point to that new
javascript entry point we can't avoid
that right the file is fundamentally
changing
but the bigger dependency of lit and
html
hasn't changed so by placing it in its
own bundle we get the benefit that it's
probably coming right out of the cache
and in a lot of browsers that means not
only the bytes from the network but also
the parsed
javascript file that's ready to go and
ready to be used
don't do this for every single file we
don't want millions of these because
it's kind of self-defeating with the
number of checks you've got to do
but for a few core large dependencies
this can be really valuable
so i've talked a lot about build tools
and hashing in the abstract
what i'd encourage you to do is check
out tooling.report for a comparison of
different build tools
and it has it does list currently
webpack
and rollup which i've mentioned and of
course the really important takeaway
here is that hashing is going to be a
huge saver for you because these files
that you generate can be made immutable
it also mentions
it also includes a tool called parcel
this is a bit newer than roll up and
webpack
it's a bit more holistic it tends to
reach into your html and actually change
these hashes for you
so a lot of the stuff i've mentioned is
not so relevant but it's also different
than your these other tools so please
check out the tooling report site to
have a look
so finally i think a talk from google
isn't complete without a section on
service workers
which are fundamentally these things
that only run on the second load so we
very much care about them for this tour
they give you a whole extra cash you can
do what you like with it a common
pattern is to use workbooks to inject a
file manifest everything
you need to run the site and then a
runtime cache for everything else
and then the big question people ask
when building a service worker is
are you going network first or cache
first there's a few more strategies that
than that but that's really the big one
cache first is great for apps and tools
in web.dev's case however especially
after our little hiccup back at the
start of the talk
we decided to go network first because
every time we go to the network we get a
new html file
we're confident that our second load
works properly and most of the
advice i've given pretty much already
applies here we have a service worker
cache that we can hit for immutable
assets along the way that we know about
but otherwise you'll always get the
newest freshest content
we don't have any weird ux issues we
don't need a reload button
and this is what i mean if you go cache
first it's very common that you have
this ux problem
it's a big sign of a service worker
driven site and when you make this
decision to show this
ui you're fundamentally saying i want to
load fast at all costs
there's nothing inherently wrong with
that and lots of google's guidance
actually does encourage this
the issue here is that for me most
reload ux is just not that good
i suspect the average user kind of
ignores it in many ways it breaks their
mental model
the websites don't work like this they
don't need updating what's this weird
button telling me to do
but this button in the end exists for a
single reason you're trying to avoid a
single round trip to check for an update
and unfortunately the web doesn't really
give you a chance
really to check for updates while our
website is closed there is a new api
the periodic background sync api which i
talk about in my article
but it only works in chrome and only
works if a web app is already installed
on a home screen
so in reality it's not a general purpose
solution
so you only really get to check whether
a site is out of date
in the extremely brief time between when
a user goes to your site by clicking on
the icon or
typing the url and when it displays
so considering that time to time between
user's intent
and a site load maybe that is long
enough to go to the network
i pose this idea to you that perhaps you
don't need to be entirely cache first
the service worker does give you a bunch
of controls
rather than blindly serving a file from
a cache first experience
you could decide on a budget to check
whether a site is up to date
there are some concerns about this
approach you know why would i block a
user from getting to my site but
as this is a second load we know the
user wants to come back
maybe you can decide on a budget for me
it's worth 50 or 100 milliseconds
to see whether something is out of date
and give the user a great second
experience
so thanks for listening it's been a long
talk and i hope you've learned something
again let me say that i've written an
article which covers a lot of this
content and you can check it out in the
description below
to restate my original point i want to
talk about the well-lit path again
i think the defaults from years gone by
aren't that great for modern
intertwined sites you should try to
disable classical caching
and instead use the cdn with good etag
validation you should opt indication
where you need to
and have a better understanding of your
caching rules um having
simpler and clearer defined rules will
reduce your complexity and reduce the
complexity loading on your brain
i think for web.dev we were backed into
a corner by
a poor understanding about cache and a
real desire to be as fast as possible
and planning a better strategy now means
we're in a better position to operate
so let's finally recap a modern sensible
default is
not cached by default and it said opt-in
where it makes sense
and it makes sense a lot of the time and
make sure your site's layout on disk
works well to support these kind of
things these immutable assets
so you can opt in lots of files and
finally if you're building a service
worker driven site
consider whether going to the network
does make sense for you
i think it often does and purely cache
only just presents you often with a
confusing or basically ignored user
experience
thanks for listening today i really hope
you've enjoyed the cds talk
and check out some of my colleagues
other great content
[Music]
bye